philippe froguel bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france la
haute autorité sanitaire vient donc de
se prononcer vacciner en priorité les
résidents des ehpad puis les personnels
de santé
c'est la bonne stratégie adoptée en
attendant une diffusion plus importante
des doses de vaccin selon vous c'est la
stratégie en tout cas pour protéger les
hôpitaux contre un afflux de patients et
diminuer la mortalité puisque c'est
avant tout les gens âgés qui décède
ça sera probablement très efficace là
dessus par contre ça ne va absolument
rien changé la diffusion du virus et
empêcher n'empêchera pas l'arrivée d'une
troisième vague puisque ce ne sont pas
les personnes âgées qui transmettent le
virus mais plutôt les personnes les plus
jeunes justement pour éviter la
progression ou l'apparition même d'une
troisième vague
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire tester
davantage la population isoler les
malades
il faut faire des dépistages de masse
c'est ce qu'un certain nombre de gens de
rentrer dont je suis propose en ce
moment au gouvernement pour vraiment
réduire le nombre de personnes porteurs
sains ce qu'on appelle les uns
symptomatique et éviter que le virus
redémarre à la fin du confinement
mais la vaccination c'est quelque chose
qui arrivera progressivement et donc
c'est pas un miracle cette vaccination
alors justement concernant la
vaccination un récent sondage ifop pour
le jdd montre que 59% des français ne
veulent pas se faire vacciner pourquoi
un tel scepticisme selon vous il ya en
france à 50 de gens qui ont été un peu
échaudé par l'expérience précédente du
strass et et qui ne croient pas dans les
vaccins
je pense qu'ils ont tort à cela dit fois
surtout pas rendre obligatoire ce vaccin
il faut laisser ouvert pour tous ceux
qui veulent faire de toute façon il y
aura pas assez de vaccins pour tout le
monde donc ça posera pas un problème
énorme ce refus de certains vous
préconisez justement de tester
massivement la population pour éviter un
rebond n'est actuellement en pleine
première phase de déconfinement un
déconfinement progressif est ce que la
stratégie du gouvernement est bonne on
sait qu'il y a les fêtes de noël qui
approche même si le gouvernement a donné
certaines directives à suivre ce que
vous prend vous pensez que les français
vous faire attention
la stratégie du gouvernement pouvait pas
être tellement différente puisqu'il
reste encore une grosse circulation du
virus et donc il fallait faire un
déconfinement qui est progressive que ça
parce qu on a trop tardé en septembre
octobre à prendre les mesures les
mesures actuelles mais il faut en plus
vraiment traquer les derniers cas de
portage asymptomatique des virus c'est
pour ça que
on propose non seulement des tests
massif d'une aussi des testings un peu
systématique et répétée
chez des personnes âgées des populations
à risque par exemple dans les
universités si on veut rouvrir exercie
t'es plutôt falloir faire c'est ces
testings très rapidement dès le mois de
janvier ou en tout cas en février si on
les voit pas avant le mois de février
le coc vie de 19 s'est invitée dans nos
vies depuis le printemps
beaucoup attendent le vaccin on l'a dit
un certain français qui sont quand même
réticent vous parlez de tester
massivement mais qu'en est il du
traitement contre cette maladie
hélas aujourd'hui les deux traitements
qui ont été testées et l om d hiver elle
hydroxy chloroquine pas montré une très
grande efficacité
y a que la gagne avec des maires d'exams
états zone mais c'est dans les formats
extrêmement grave
là sous oxygène il y a quelques petites
pistes aujourd'hui mais ça mettra du
temps à celles qui sont testés par
exemple à l'institut pasteur de lille
je crois qu'il faut les suivre parce que
on a bien vu récemment qui a d'autres
virus de ce type qui risque d'arriver
dans les prochaines années et on a un
très très grand retard dans les
traitements antiviraux
merci beaucoup philippe froguel d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur et professeur une
perial collège de londres ainsi qu'à
l'université de lille